triste
más que una resolución el texto 2.593
aprobado por el consejo de seguridad de
la onu interpela al honor de los
talibanes aunque les instan a cumplir
sus compromisos en afganistán sus puntos
son una petición constante al grupo gas
no el consejo espera que el talibán hará
efectiva las salidas de los afganos y
extranjeros que quieran marcharse de
forma segura y ordenada así como una
entrada a la ayuda de naciones unidas
pero además les solicita respetar los
derechos humanos de mujeres niños y
minorías intentar llegar a una solución
política que incluye a las afganas no
usar el país para amenazar atacar o
acoger a terroristas y finalmente le
pide cumplir con esta y otras promesas
futuras
no podemos llevar por aire a todo un
país hasta un lugar seguro este es el
momento en el que la diplomacia debe
intensificarse al aprobar esta
resolución el consejo de seguridad ha
demostrado que el mundo espera que el
talibán cumple estas promesas hoy mañana
y después del 31 de agosto story force
13 de 15 países miembros tuvieron de
acuerdo en el tono tildado por analistas
de ligero y de mensaje político al
movimiento francia que buscaba
establecer una zona segura en kabul para
presionar y proteger el aeropuerto no
logró una referencia mientras que china
y rusia se abstuvieron alegando desorden
de accidente fuga de cerebros y efectos
económicos nocivos para el país a pesar
de que la resolución fue propuesta con
el telón de fondo de un terrible ataque
terrorista los autores se negaron
categóricamente a referirse a un pasaje
de la lucha contra el terrorismo que
contiene organizaciones terroristas
reconocidas internacionalmente
si bien la resolución busca transmitir
unión internacional la pelota está en
tejado talibán que ya declaró la total
independencia de afganistán